well streaking plays a cameo in the
movie which I love who doesn't have you
ever really done that I have yes I have
as well I've streaked before yeah I
streaked across uh in the middle of my
campus when I was in college oh my God
you're totally like old school we're
going streaking in the quad
that's amazing it wasn't our quad
actually it literally was in our quad
there's a basketball deer I played
myself playing college basketball and it
was a dare it wasn't a dare it was like
it was a dare uh more or less let's just
call it from like a bunch of my
teammates we were all together one night
and uh myself and one of my other
teammates straight across campus at like
one o'clock in the morning nudity is
funny nudity is funny it's funny it's
funny it's great it's funny when you're
running too you know it's just all that
you know everything's just out there you
know streaking is different when you get
older
it's a little more sloppy because it's a
little different I don't know like this
doesn't feel as good I don't care but
y'all probably do
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]